today on the matt walsh show the media
celebrates the youngest trans model in
the country the child is only 10 and his
story far from inspirational is tragic
and terrifying also after a disastrous
career dr fauci finally decides to go
away sort of a university sets up black
only housing to protect black students
from white violence they say the toronto
police brag about seizing a firearm that
was manufactured during the french and
indian war michael jackson fans are mad
at harry styles and in our daily
cancellation can college students name
our country's capital do they even know
that we have a capital we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt
walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
in a society rife with anti-religious
ideologies like the ones we hear from
the left on a daily basis it can be
incredibly challenging to ground oneself
in what we know to be true and good to
keep from
descending into distrust frustration or
even hatred that's why i find god's
peace every day through prayer and
meditation with hallow hallow is the
number one christian prayer app in the
u.s and the number one catholic app in
the world it's rooted in catholic
tradition but it's an amazing resource
for any christian looking to dive deeper
into their prayer life hallow has
prayers and meditations to guide you
throughout the entire day morning
tonight and this week hallow is
launching its exclusive athlete prayers
join some of the best christian athletes
in the world like brett favre and lou
holtz for some motivational and
inspirational meditations to help you
get off your lazy butt and get to the
gym or train for a race or sport hello
now not only will help your spiritual
health it will also help your physical
health as well let hallow help you find
your peace and strength throughout your
day try it for three months free at
hallow.com matt walsh or text pray to
one eight five five nine four four five
six eight four that's hallowed dot com
slash matt walsh or text pray to
1-855-944-5684
for three months free reclaim your peace
in this crazy world download hallow
today
back in october of 2020 a woman named
sarah melger brought her then one month
old baby to the hospital reporting that
the child suffered from a number of uh
serious health problems she said that he
wouldn't eat and he was constantly
vomiting she had told the child's father
that he had a fever of 102.5
which is a dangerous temperature for a
child that age
she said that he had heart defects she
told other family members that the baby
suffered from hearing problems as well
as um down syndrome twice over the
course of two months the hospital
performed spinal taps on the baby
inserting a needle in between two
vertebrae to test him for sepsis
a couple of months later she was back at
the hospital frantically claiming that
the child wouldn't eat and he was
dehydrated so a feeding tube was
inserted
over time the stories about the child's
medical problems became increasingly
dramatic
and disturbing
and also fictional there was no sepsis
there was no fever there was no vomiting
or hearing problems or eating problems
the child didn't have down syndrome
sarah melger had made all of that up it
was munchausen by proxy a disorder where
a caretaker almost always a mother
pretends that a child is sick and she
does this for attention or for sympathy
maybe because she derives some sort of
sick satisfaction from watching her
child suffer perhaps it's a combination
of these things whatever her twisted
reasons melder was eventually arrested
and charged and finally this summer
convicted of three counts of injury to a
child
now her sentence community supervision
was outrageously lenient
but at least she won't be able to
contact your child who certainly is
better off now never seeing his deranged
abusive mother
ever again
but munchausen takes other more
pervasive and even more disturbing forms
worst of all these other forms that it
takes are perfectly legal
by the standards of our laws today
more than legal actually they're
celebrated
they may even result in a modeling
contract so this month a ten-year-old
boy named noella mcmahor
has been making headlines as the
youngest quote trans model in the
country now of course it would be creepy
and inappropriate to put a 10 year old
on the runway no matter what you know
whether
whether whether it's a boy or a girl
and most everyone agrees in most
situations that it's creepy and
inappropriate as things like you know
child beauty pageants have finally
fallen out of favor in recent years and
rightfully so
but exceptions are made for cases like
this boy because he allegedly does not
identify as a boy
you know in our culture it is wildly
offensive to dress little girls up in
lots of makeup and parade them around
and it should be seen as offensive but
it's beautiful and brave to do the exact
same thing to a little boy
outlets like out magazine have been
raving about noella reading now from
their article says ten-year-old noella
mcmahor is already making her dreams
come true six years after she began
transitioning
six years
okay the child is ten
noella has made history as the youngest
out trans model ever to walk a runway
during new york fashion week when she
walked from designer mel atkinson and
trans clothing company walked for them
rather noella doesn't ever get nervous
or scared by anything she's a tiny
professional duelo's mother dee mcmaher
told metro uk
she was so excited to go down the
catwalk excited to see all the people
and the cameras she knows exactly how to
work a crowd
we are so proud of noella for being the
first trans child in new york fashion
week were in awe of her confidence and
determination she continued noella
already has so many transgender people
of all ages contact her for advice and
support
a 10 year old is being asked for advice
and support
indeed people of all ages adults even
apparently are consulting this
prepubescent child for advice
now i suppose it's no surprise that a
mother would put her child in the
position of providing guidance to adults
given that she's already put him in the
position of being a runway model
speaking of the mother the glowing media
profiles
seem oddly reluctant to tell us much
about the child's home life
they tell us a little bit
some of the basics
but what exactly is going on at home
and when you investigate the subject you
immediately understand why they're so
hesitant
the website redux has a report today
revealing some of the rather dark
details
about what uh noella is dealing with at
home
here's what they report at age four
noella was socially transitioned it was
around this time that noella's mother
said that she brought the child to
therapy at the gender development clinic
at anne and robert h laurie children's
hospital chicago
during the appointments noella told a
gender counselor that he was a girl by
age six noella's legal documentation had
already been changed
d mcmahor noella's biological mother is
a social justice advocate who identifies
as non-binary appears to be on hormone
replacement therapy and recently had a
cosmetic mastectomy both she and her
current partner are females who identify
as trans masculine
according to the point foundation
website mcmahon has been an advocate and
educator for transgender children for 10
years roughly since around the time
noella was born
in 2019 mcmahon nuella were featured in
people's world during a legal episode in
which mcmahon was fighting for full
custody of her child from her biological
father
uh timothy mccord
or from his biological father right
the report goes on to reveal that mccord
the father did not agree uh with his
son's transition didn't agree that his
son was transgender he opposed the
transition but he lost the ability to
prevent it in 2016 after mcmahon claimed
that the father fractured the boy's arm
while trying to force him into quote boy
pajamas mccord was arrested for child
abuse uh mcmahon also pressed to have
him charged with an anti-trans hate
crime the hate crime charge never
materialized but mccord did plead down
to a lesser charge and was given
probation
meanwhile mcmahon the mother
married a female named ray
who also identifies as trans and works
in the field of quote lgbtq health
justice
now in 2019 noella mccord was profiled
by the website chicago parent under the
headline
seven-year-old stands up for transgender
rights
in the article the mother brags about
her trans child
claiming that she transitioned him as a
toddler so that he could feel safe and
be happy
and she says that her son is brave and
fierce and a force to be reckoned with
these are all descriptions that don't
describe
any seven-year-old i've ever met because
seven-year-olds are small children they
are not forces to be reckoned with
but that's how the mother sees the child
he is not a child at all but a political
and ideological cudgel to be wielded
he's a mascot to be paraded around
he's an accessory a fashion statement
he's also a thing to be experimented on
and on that note
the chicago parent article contains this
passage
quote dee is looking forward to watching
ella continue to grow and turn into the
person she is and was meant to be
in the next few years she will start
puberty blockers and hormones and begin
the physical transition process with
gender surgeries at 16.
so they've already decided
for him
that he's going to get the drugs in the
surgery
they decided this while the child was
still in diapers
they shoved him down this path and cut
off all the exits by publicly declaring
his gender identity to the world and
putting him in the position of being an
inspiration and a force
you know when a source of wisdom and
guidance for the whole lgbt community
you can't change his mind now
of course he can't because he never made
up his mind to begin with this isn't his
mind choosing any of this it's his
mother
manipulating and controlling him
it is exactly like sarah melger
in that case right down to the
unnecessary medical procedures
the only difference is that the typical
munchausen mommy
is out for attention and sympathy mainly
and there's an element of that here as
well certainly dee mcmahor wants
attention no question about that
but she's also looking to her child for
something else
that i think is a little bit of a twist
from the average uh munchausen case
she's looking for affirmation
so it is actually not a misnomer to say
that when a parent trans is a child she
is engaging in the process of
affirmation it's actually true
it is affirmation
but it's affirmation of herself
not her child a child like doesn't even
exist her child has no face no identity
he's a canvas a blank screen that his
mother projects her fantasies and
delusions onto
nobody exists
but to affirm her
this is especially true of her child
she makes her child sick
so that she can feel well
and rather than handcuffs and criminal
charges
all she gets in response is
applause
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know with two
new babies on the way it's uh i'm gonna
be going we're going through a time in
our lives when sleep is going to be at a
premium to put it mildly which is all
the more reason why i am thankful for my
helix mattress you know helix mattress
has several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains
and even a helix plus size mattress for
plus sized sleepers very important as
well to include the plus size community
in your mattresses they also have a
sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences for the perfect
mattress because why would you buy a
mattress made for somebody else so if
you're looking for a mattress take the
quiz order the mattress and uh wait for
the delivery it's really as simple as
that your mattress will come right to
your door for free you don't ever need
to go to a mattress store again they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will trust me
helix has over 12 000 five-star reviews
their financing options and flexible
payment plans make it make it so that a
great night's sleep is never far away
for anyone for a limited time helix is
offering up to 350 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for
my listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry over to helixsleep.com
walsh today
well another sad day first we lost
jeffrey toobin
then brian stelter
and now tony fauci
we are rapidly losing all of our most
insufferable douchebags it's a full-on
crisis
i'm really getting worried about keith
olbermann at this point
i guess we already lost him he like
doesn't is he even still alive i'm not
sure um so it's it's it's a pretty big
it's a pretty bad it's pretty big
problem and uh cnbc has the report the
nation's top infectious disease expert
dr anthony fauci plans to step down from
his role running the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases and
advising the white house as his chief
medical advisor at the end of the year
he announced on monday
and in a statement he says after more
than 50 years of government service i
plan to pursue the next phase of my
career while i still have so much energy
and passion for my field i want to use
what i've learned as the director
to continue to advance science and
public health and to inspire and mentor
the next generation of scientific
leaders as they help prepare the world
to face future infectious disease
experts
the next phase of my career he's talking
like he's like 42
and he's it is he's making a career
change
you're in your 80s
just go away go go
sit on a rocking chair
and be retired
stop inflicting yourself on the rest of
the world
it is it's an absolute scourge this this
generation of boomers
who've been running the government
for like 30 years and they won't let go
they just won't leave us alone
you've done a terrible job okay this
generation of leaders have just it's
been an
unmitigated disaster
you have ruined everything everything in
the country is worse now than it was
when you took over
yeah you're like the first generation
that's gonna leave your kids generation
uh worse off than you were poorer than
you were
so just leave
please
not that what we haven't coming up next
is gonna be much better probably but but
even so
now i do think that fauci um
provided a valuable public service in
some way you know in his career
not any sort of public health service
right he's been a disaster again on that
front
but um as every crisis that he oversaw
only got worse he made everything worse
100 of the time but he has provided the
service i think of showing
just how power corrupts in the context
of a modern bureaucracy right so we you
know we know the saying that power
corrupts but
when we think of the corrupting
influence of power i think we tend to
think about emperors and kings and
dictators we think about like caligula
nero or somebody like that but
what
fauci shows us is what it looks like
in the context of a modern bureaucracy
in a western country
looks a little bit different
and that fauci is this mediocre
nobody he is this utterly unimpressive
talentless
stupid hack he should be
working as a shift supervisor at a
rental car agency with all due respect
people work rental car ages but but
that's that's the world he should be in
but instead he ended up in the
government
and he's just drifting along
failing failing failing for 50 years
flubbing his way along
flubbing and fumbling
but he stays there because there's no
mechanism for getting rid of somebody
like that in a bureaucracy the
bureaucracy exists to protect people
like that
and so the only person that can make
them leave is themselves
he didn't want to do that and so just it
uh it just because he lasts the longest
like a war of attrition he just he just
kind of lasts the longest and ends up as
the highest paid and most influential
guy in the government
having not earned any of that prestige
or any of that money or any of it
that's the way it works in a so it's
it's not unlike
um
the kind of corruption that we have seen
historically
maybe the only difference is that
never before in history have such
mediocre people have been so enabled you
know
to become
this powerful
in the past at least it required even if
you didn't have any governing talent you
had to be
you know
you have to had to be charismatic or
you'd have something
that that you know puts you in a
position of having all this power but um
but not not the case anymore
no career not even charisma nothing
no talent
fauci uh
on his way out the door offered his
reflections on what we've learned from
the covid pandemic
and um
no surprise here he apparently has not
learned anything at all let's watch
we've been fooled before
we didn't fully appreciate the magnitude
of hiv back in the early 80s when i
first got involved when the first cases
were recognized
and there were so many things we learned
on the run
with covid i mean the things that we
thought we knew in the beginning turned
out as the months went by
to not be the case which really
forced us to adapt and to change some of
our policies and recommendations
that was interpreted by many as
flip-flopping or not really knowing
what's going on when it really was the
evolution
of the science so one of the lessons
that i hope we learn
is that we've got to be prepared
we've got to be able to respond but
we've also got to be flexible
oh we we uh we learned
you know there are things we thought in
the beginning and then and then we
learned and and
fauci was accused of flip-flop but he
didn't flip-flop
well what exactly did we learn that we
didn't know at the beginning
or what did what did you need to learn
because
most of the stuff you're saying we
didn't know
well i knew
almost everyone watching this right now
knew
there were like people on twitter
with no special insight into this
situation no medical training
no access no special access to the data
the only data we had was just what the
media told us
and yet we almost immediately
said things that it took fouchy two
years to say so how did we know it lucky
guess is that it
that's that's the excuse that that he
uses about the science change or what we
know about the science change
but what how did it change
many of us said from the very beginning
that the social distancing six feet rule
makes no sense it's a totally arbitrary
thing
that we've that that has been imposed on
us for no good reason
and it took a couple years and
eventually we were told oh yeah well
there's really there was really no
science but six feet like what how is
why is six feet a magic number
and especially when the
you know the
not just covet but any kind of virus can
linger in the air
so you stay six feet from someone
walking like single file line
through through a grocery aisle you know
and it's always like one way you
remember that during covered the one-way
signs in the grocery aisles
well if the person in front of you is
exhaling or they're coughing or whatever
you're going to walk through that mist
anyway what's the six feet gonna do for
you
completely arbitrary um
many of us from the very beginning said
yeah these cloth masks everybody are
wearing everybody's wearing what is this
going to do exactly
is the virus not small enough to pass
through the fibers of the cotton mask
took him a long time to finally come
around to that well actually not because
fauci if you recall um he was right
about that originally
i think it was in in uh march of 2020
he came out and said the masks aren't
really going to do anything for you the
masks you know there's no reason to wear
the masks and then a month later
he said never mind everybody needs to
wear the mask we went from
stop wearing the masks to actually if
you don't everybody needs to learn if
you don't wear them then you're
murdering your grandparents
and then about two years later they
circled back around and said oh yeah you
know what the thing we were saying at
the very beginning was that was was
basically correct correct
none of this has anything to do with
science of course fauci knows this is
this was not the process or evolution of
science what it was
was the the evolution of the political
evolution
that's what it was
all right this is from the college fix
it says white guests are banned from the
common spaces at the person of color
house an off-campus housing option for
berkeley students according to a photo
of the guest rules recently posted on
reddit
under a section labeled guests in common
spaces it states
guests are allowed in common spaces but
please be mindful if there are house
members in the room beforehand
white guests are not allowed in common
spaces
the poc house
states in part that many members moved
in to be able to avoid white violence
and presence
when and where is this again this is a
berkeley of course when students do
bring a guest the rules direct them to
announce it in the house guest chat and
note if they are white
so if you're in the poc house and you
want to bring a white guest
which probably you wouldn't even want to
do that because you're only there
because you're
a racist scumbag but uh
so when you bring when you bring the
white guests you have to announce
white guy coming through
i want to know what exactly is the
announcement what are you supposed to
say
white we got a white
but it's not just white guests who are
unwelcome it says avoid bringing parents
and family members that express bigotry
queer black and indigenous members
should not have to avoid common spaces
because of homophobic or racist parents
and family members
now
uh
like it of course goes without saying
that
it's unthinkable that any university in
the country would have a white house
only
set up um that could not exist you know
if there was a university
that had um
they had the the house for the poc house
right so they got the black house
and then they also set up a white house
and they called it that
the house for the white people would be
burned to the ground
and nobody who set it on fire would go
to jail for it
like they could just set it on fire with
people inside they could actually you
could have the white people in the in
the house for white people inside it
burn it to the ground and kill everybody
and no one respond who did it would go
to even go to jail for it
but it wouldn't come to that because
it's unthinkable right we live in a
supposedly supposedly uh
systemically racist
society systemically racist against
black people and yet it is unthinkable
that any institution would ever set up
anything specifically for white people
and yet they do this you know for quote
poc all the time
it's wildly illegal
it's completely illegal
uh
racial segregation in housing is illegal
but
as we have seen
especially for
recently and frequently
you know the laws are just not enforced
if you're on the left
and that's what systemic privilege
really is
there is systemic privilege
um it's not really determined by race
it's it's it is it's partially identity
based
you're more likely to to um be able to
take advantage of systemic privilege if
you have identity points black gay trans
whatever
but really it's ideological
most of all
because something tells me that even in
the poc house right
they say this is no this is open for uh
people of color
but something tells me that if that i
don't know if um
if candace owens
decided she wanted to attend berkeley
which would be pretty funny i don't
think she'd be welcome in the poc house
something tells me
this is also by the way the definition
of gaslighting
you know this
we're constantly told about white
violence
and that um racial minorities
have to stay away from white people
because they're afraid of the violence
they'll inflict
total gaslighting
we hear that phrase all the time but
this is actually gaslighting
there is
you know if you're a
black person
the chance that you're going to be the
victim of violence
that you're going to be vic that you're
going to become the victim of a violent
attack from a white person is almost
non-existent
it is almost certainly not going to
happen it's of all the things you have
to worry about
an attack from a white person is like
is i don't even know if it makes it into
the top 100.
it's not impossible
but it's almost certainly not going to
happen
and as everyone knows who's looked at
the statistics if you are a black person
and you become the victim of violence it
is almost definitely going to be
another black person who inflicts that
on you that's just what the statistics
tell you
and they also tell you
that statistically a black person is
much more likely to violently attack a
white person than the other way around
okay the data doesn't lie here
it is what it is
and yet in spite of that the only thing
we ever hear about is white violence
all right here's an update on a story we
talked about yesterday it says as from
the daily wire it says the school
administrator for a devoutly christian
florida school says he and his family
have received numerous violent threats
because of the school's firm stand
affirming biblical morality
grace christian school has stood firm in
its stance asking lgbtq students to
leave and referring to students only by
their biological
sex
um administrator barry mckean wrote
parents in january on june 6th rather
well i read this to you saying that um
you know this is
god created mankind in his image male
and female he created them which means
that there's only two biological sex
sexes and that's the only thing we
recognize and we're only going to
recognize a child according to their
biological sex not according to
their uh
gender fluid notions or whatever else
and that's what they announced
and now um
this uh this administrator has been
targeted for violence and or threats of
violence and death threats and
everything else
which
rings completely true to me i have no
doubt at all that he's getting
uh messages and and things like that
because i get them all the time
and
you know of all the things that you can
come out and say publicly
or all the positions that you can adopt
publicly
the one that's
most likely to provoke death threats is
uh you know if you're criticizing the
lgbt community especially anything to do
with trans
and given that he's in stating this
policy in his school
and actually kicking kids out if they're
not going to abide by it then yeah you
could only imagine i can only imagine
what his inbox looks like
i can only imagine what might actually
happen to this school talk about getting
burned to the ground
and one of the reasons why you get this
violent response
is that um
the message from our culture
like justifies the violence from lgbt
people by telling them that well if
somebody criticizes you or someone
doesn't agree with your lifestyle then
they are they are a threat to your
existence
they're genocidal they're gonna they
they're they're killing you somehow
by someone simply
stating their opinion
about the trans stuff if they don't
agree with it then they are killing you
that's the message
which obviously sets the groundwork for
the person who's being violently
attacked by an opinion to respond
violently
and then claim self-defense
all right i want to show this to you i
thought this was pretty great um
the toronto police will often post
photos bragging about the guns that they
take off the street you know making the
community safer and all that
and here's the latest uh seizure and as
you can see it's a gun from the
cretaceous period that they've managed
to take off the streets the gun i mean
it's it is literally fossilized okay
they took a fossilized gun off the
streets and they're
bragging about it
i'm glad we have it now i am glad
because now we can finally uh
we finally have the evidence to put that
woolly mammoth in prison
it is it's just absurd
this is this is the weapon that was used
to kill the dinosaurs right there
i know i'm mixing all the prehistoric
eras together here with dinosaurs and
wooly mammoths but you know you get the
point
just glad finally glad
that that weapon that was last when was
the last time that that weapon was
actually used all joking aside
maybe a hundred years ago
at the most recent
all right um
rolling stone has provoked some outrage
this
week with um a new cover that which is
uh the harry styles cover and as you can
see the outrage it's not because he
looks incredibly
stupid he's got i don't know what he's
got some kind of
sequins uh
boxers on and a fur coat
holding a birthday cake
anyway it says harry styles
how the new king of pop
set the music world aflame
and that's what upsets people is that he
says that's king of pop
and this is a controversy now because
it's it's appropriating from michael
jackson so newsweek has
the report it says harry styles has
inadvertently upset passionate michael
jackson fans after a magazine referred
to him as the new king of pop
jackson's fans and even his nephew taj
jackson voiced their displeasure at
stiles's new apparent title the october
november issue of rolling stone uk
magazine features uh former one
direction singer styles on the front
cover where he's awarded his new royal
title
uh but people are very upset about that
thousands upon thousands of jackson fans
spoke out on twitter
quote there is no new king of pop you
don't own the title rolling stone and
you didn't earn it my uncle did michael
jackson's nephew taj wrote on twitter
retweeting the cover shoot decades of
dedication and sacrifice this title has
been retired no disrespect to harry
styles he's mega talented give him his
own unique title
community actress uh yvette nicole brown
weighed in
and says
um
agrees with that and then a bunch of
other people okay whatever people are
upset a bunch of michael jackson fans
are very upset about this because
michael jackson is the king of pot pop
just two things i want to point out here
first of all
michael jackson was a pedophile
so he doesn't deserve to retain any
titles at all
okay so that just getting offended on
his behalf he's a dead pedophile
and so
we take away all his titles
i mean we we ripped down monuments left
and right
and we're ripping down monuments taking
the founding fathers names off of school
buildings and everything else
and yet we're still worried about
protecting the good name of a monstrous
freak
pedophile here's the thing about michael
jackson
there was nothing good about him
but he could dance that's it he just he
was a good dancer
and he made some songs that were kind of
catchy i'll give him that
um
and then he also raped children so
i i'm not sure how i see the the good
the good dancing outweighs the raping of
children
and on top of that he was just a freak
so
if we're look
if we were deciding as a society to just
sort of leave history alone
and uh and not rip down the monuments
and statues and everything like that
then maybe i would say that yeah michael
jackson was a pedophile freak and a
child abuser but uh okay he was awarded
the title king of pop and sure he can
keep it because that's
but
we can't have it both ways here
like if we're going back in history and
we're we we are um
taking superlatives away from people and
reevaluating them and and taking away
their honorifics
because of the bad things they did then
i'm not sure how we
gloss over michael jackson
second point though is that i actually
agree that harry styles is not the king
of pop um
you know i i've never even heard a harry
styles song i don't think i don't think
i've ever i couldn't i certainly
couldn't name for you one harry styles
song i couldn't tell you if i heard if i
heard of him singing i wouldn't be able
to tell you that it was him
because even though he's
massively successful and famous and
millions of people
have
heard his music apparently he doesn't
have the kind of cultural impact
that michael jackson did have
or that elvis had before
and that's just because that's the
culture we live in now
it's just not it's not possible for
anyone to have that kind of impact
anymore
everything is just sort of fractured
into a million pieces and there are a
million celebrities it's like anyone and
fame is so cheap now anyone can be
famous anyone can make something and
and put it out there and and you know
millions of people will encounter it
there are um
you know i was very happy when i crossed
a million subscribers on youtube
it's a big accomplishment for me
there are youtube channels out there
with a hundred
million subscribers
like 50 million 100 million
and then you go and you check out those
channels
and there's
there's nothing there like there are
channels where they
all they do is reactions and so
they watch other people's videos and
they don't say anything interesting
about them they don't riff on them in an
interesting way they don't say anything
they just watch someone else's video
and then maybe they go that's wild
and that'll get 50 million views and
there's a hundred million dollars like a
multi-millionaire is doing that
that's how cheap fame is and also and
also how splintered and fractured it is
so you can have someone with like
hundreds of millions of fans
and yet outside of that bubble no one
even has even heard of that person
so that's the world we live in now and
that's part of the reason why
there actually will never be
another king of pop
so i say that in in a certain way in you
know in defense of the critics here
although still michael jackson's a child
raping pedophile so
all right
one other thing i want to mention before
we get to the comment section and um
probably the most important piece of
footage i can play for you today
this was a video taken at a baseball
game
um
let's get this up on the screen so this
is a guy
not a lot of explanation we don't know
who this guy is we don't know where he
comes from
but go ahead and play the video all we
know
is that he was sitting there he got a
hot dog at the baseball game
and he uses a straw
to hollow out
the hot dog
and then look at what he does next
dear god in heaven
he uses
the hot dog
as a straw in the beer
no shame at all no shame
you know he doesn't care that people are
he's like you know you would you would
think at the very least
if you're the kind of person who drinks
beer through a hot dog straw
i don't know if that's really a kind of
person or just like there's just one of
them but you would think that you kind
of he'd be looking around to make sure
that nobody's watching him do this
um
that's like right that's me anytime if i
do something even mildly unusual in
public i'm kind of looking
right but but he's got no shame he's
just he's just this is how he enjoys the
beer you have to respect that to a
certain extent
and people are making fun of this guy
you know he's getting mocked all over
the internet
but don't don't judge this man
we don't we don't know his reasons
okay we don't really know no one has
stopped and asked him
and not only that
you take away the plastic straws
and then you judge a man for what he has
what's he's what he's forced to do
of course that doesn't really work
because you could just and you should
just drink the beer without a straw and
also he did have a straw that he used to
make the hot dog straw but still i just
you know my point is
we have we have created a lot of
confusion in the straw area and so i
think that's part of what leads to
situations like this
all right
let's get to the comment section
matt's pronunciation of
taqiria was almost as good as dr jill
biden's production pronunciation of the
word bodega how are you supposed to
pronounce it i don't know how do you
pronounce this word does anyone know
controlling do you know
taqueria
taqueria
what is attackeria
anyone know
what is it
taco shell okay like i'm supposed to
know that
oh taco shop okay fine
so the voice of god was speaking to me
to correct me uh
so
no no okay
don't don't give me that there was a lot
of comments like every comment was
because i mispronounced that word so i'm
supposed to know how to how to pronounce
that like that's a
is that is that a common household term
really do you go around in your house
talking about taqiria
if you want to go get a taco do you say
oh i'm going to the mexican place get a
taco you say i'm going to the taqiria no
you don't say that so don't judge me for
this
first you judge the guy with the hot dog
straw and now you judge me
um vole princess says when life gives
you snakes make dinner
uh when that well that needs to be on a
t-shirt oh it's quoting me yeah when
life gives you snakes make dinner i did
say that uh that needs to be on t-shirt
i i agree that maybe we should make a
t-shirt that's that that's an
inspirational slogan that is meaningful
not just to my to my son but uh i think
to all of us and speaking of the daily
wire shop by the way
those who are watching on the video
podcast you can see this sticker that i
have on the back of my laptop here this
is our what is a woman definition
circular definition sticker so a woman
is someone who identifies as a woman
going around in circles forever and ever
uh and if you want that sticker they are
for sale at the daily wire shop right
now the matt walsh
store
uh go to dailywire.com
shop and you can find it there
let's see
scott says matt you know you're gonna
have to name one of your new sons hugh
jar sol walsh and while you're at it
name the other one scott to honor your
biggest fan how dare you these are my
children you're talking about
although i will suggest that to my wife
because she's gonna be so annoyed
and it'll be funny
stevo says matt's pronunciation of
greenwich as grenwich bothered me at
first a man with mass intelligence
should know it's greenwich but then i
laugh knowing that matt walsh makes no
mistakes yeah that's the other one so
every comment was
he didn't pronounce tequila right or you
mispronounced greenwich village
look look
it is spelled greenwich that's
outspelled and that's how i pronounce it
all right i am correct everyone else is
wrong everyone in in new york we call it
greenwich village you're all wrong
that's not how it's pronounced it's just
not how those that's not what that's not
the sound that those letters make i'm
sorry i hate to tell you that
and there's nothing more annoying than
people who expect you to know
local pronunciations because any any
time you go anywhere right they've got
weird ways of pronouncing some of their
some of their towns that don't really
don't really make any sense and then if
you don't pronounce it correctly
everyone judges
how did you just pronounce that
well i don't live here okay i didn't
know that that's your stupid way of
pronouncing it how am i supposed to know
that
now i know the response is well but it's
new york
it's everyone should know i don't care
it's not special
i don't care about that it's not
relevant to me well new york is so
important no it's not
it's not get over yourself
okay
um
the wifey says matt you and my husband
are the exact same with names we have
three boys boy names are hard to pick
and anytime i would ask my husband for
name suggestions he'd just look around
him and start naming things
me i would say let's talk about baby
names him
grass stop sign roundabout
yeah that's i also do the same thing uh
it's a good it's a it's a good it's a
it's a good bit i think
and you know what there is some
tradition to that like that's uh
some native american cultures you know
that's how they would name traditionally
their
children
um
if they if a baby was born
and then they looked out into the forest
and they saw a deer bounding through the
forest they would name the child
bounding beer beer or something like
that right running deer right
um so there's some tradition i think to
that
of course it you can't really apply that
to babies that are born in a hospital
very kind of sterile environment because
then all the babies will be named you
know
scalpel and
[Music]
chair and that sort of thing
another comment says matt i have to
remind you of a republican virtue
personal freedom if the finnish pm wants
to party it's no one's business to
criticize that publicly however what she
does what she did was incredibly naive
next time she might get laid by a
russian spy and be compromised forever
hopefully she'll be more careful in the
future yeah a couple of problems here
first of all isn't criticizing someone
part of personal freedom
so if my value is supposed to be the
republican virtue is allegedly personal
freedom
then
isn't that part of personal freedom that
i can criticize you that's free speech
but also i don't agree that that's the
great principle sort of republican
virtue is personal freedom
we certainly need a lot of qualification
on that what do you mean by freedom
exactly
because if what you mean is that as
republicans we're supposed to believe
that everyone can just do whatever they
want without criticism if that's what
you mean by freedom personal freedom
which appears to be what you mean then
no that is not that's not the
that
is not and certainly should not be
the republican viewpoint
that's basically what you hear from the
left that's what that is their vision of
freedom is just do whatever you want
especially sexually and not only should
you not be prevented from doing it but
no one should even criticize you for
doing it
that's freedom according to them
and uh finally
judson gordy says
if your barista is good they deserve a
tip lots of skill behind making a good
latte
and uh they make good art
all right i don't i don't deny that that
you know it it takes skill to be a good
barista but do they not receive a
paycheck already
is the barista not already paid for that
skill isn't that what the
salary is for or if they're making an
hourly wage they're getting paid
something already
so that's already built in
and the fact that the company has to pay
a salary to the employees that's also
built into the price of the thing that
i'm buying so i'm already helping to pay
by paying for my coffee i am helping to
pay the salary of the barista already
so then it's like well you want an extra
tip if they do a really good job but
that's
i expect that i expect you to do a
really good job your boss should expect
that
that's that's that's
that's required
it's like when my kids
clean their room and do a really good
job and they say oh can i have a treat
because i did a good job cleaning my
room no you can't this is what you're
supposed to do
the only other option is to be lazy and
to do a and to do a lackadaisical job
cleaning the room and just stuff things
under the bed and think i won't notice
but that's unacceptable so by doing a
good job cleaning the room you are just
doing the ex the only acceptable thing
and so i would say if you're a barista
and you're getting paid to do that for a
living the only acceptable option is to
do your best and uh provide good service
to your customers
i don't see why there should be an extra
payment on top of that
corporate media not only controls what
they want you to know but their agenda
means the news is presented to you in a
biased way you know we all know that i
know you know we all know it thankfully
there's a way to get the most important
news of the day without their narrative
and that's by listening to one of the
top news podcasts morning wire new
episodes are available every morning
seven days a week and they cover stories
other media outlets won't touch check
out morning wire apple podcast spotify
daily wire plus or wherever you listen
to podcasts do it right now in the
meantime now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well it's the kind of video we've all
seen many times before this time it's
youtuber a youtuber by the name of james
klug walking around los angeles asking
young people most of them college aged
basic questions about american history
civics and geography
and given that the questions are
extremely simple and rudimentary
everyone is able to answer them easily
and we're all left feeling pretty good
about the future of our country the end
just kidding of course none of them can
answer the questions and we're once
again reminded that we are as an as a
civilization hurtling towards a certain
destruction which will be brought about
largely by our own stupidity and
ignorance
now we know basically how these dumb guy
on the street videos go
and yet
with each new entry in this burgeoning
genre the results are no less shocking
and depressing so let's all watch
together
and then weep
how many stars are on the united states
flag
103 103
[Music]
what ocean is on the east side of the
united states what ocean
[Music]
can i google it
you guys know this
i know this
i don't know this what country is the
queen of england from
i'm not a political guy
i don't know i really don't know just
take a guess like what country is the
queen of england from
europe
what's the capital of the united states
um the
um there's a capital
what lexi take a guess um
i don't know uh probably california yeah
that's right
it is
not the united states do we know
solve i knew he was going to embarrass
us i know do you wait i didn't want to
think because i don't want to sound down
well just there's no capital yeah
literally
is there no capital
correct is that right
you guys are used yelling
ucla yeah
who was the first president of the
united
states abraham lincoln can you name the
uh three kardashian sisters
uh kim courtney and chloe what are the
three kardashian sisters names courtney
kim and chloe
chloe courtney and courtney yeah bonus
points for the brother um robert
okay well they know something then at
least
uh okay you know the video actually goes
on for over eight minutes but you get
the idea
it's hard to pick one moment as a
favorite from that one and a half minute
clip there perhaps it's the
fact that these people not only can't
name the capital united states but they
refuse to believe that we even have one
or maybe it's the fact that uh they've
somehow lived their entire lives up
until this point without knowing about
the atlantic ocean or maybe it's the
girl who said and i quote
i don't want to think because i don't
want to sound dumb
she apparently doesn't realize that not
wanting to think is exactly what's
gotten into her into her got her into
this mess to begin with
but you can't expect self-awareness from
stupid people that's um one of the
reasons why morons always end up
humiliating themselves in these kinds of
videos because you you might think that
they would
at least know that they don't know
anything and would thus decline to be
quizzed on trivia in front of a camera
but then again as socrates observed
knowing how little you know is wisdom
and these people are
anything but wise
now it's easy enough to see this sort of
thing
and dismiss it as cherry-picked and
sensationalist
surely they spoke to people who answered
all the questions with ease and
therefore didn't make the final cut and
maybe that's true you know sure but the
fact remains that anyone can grab a
camera as we've seen and a microphone
and they can walk down any busy street
in any city or across any college campus
and they can run into an endless stream
of drooling idiots who
despite being highly educated on paper
are so mind-numbingly stupid that my
five-year-old would make a better
jeopardy contestant than they would
it's also the case that these people
exist and they're walking around in
droves in spite of the fact that every
piece of simple basic knowledge they
don't possess is readily available to
them
in the information age they can't recite
the most fundamental facts about the
geography of their own country for
example even though they carry around in
their pockets a device that can in an
instant
give them access to highly detailed
satellite imagery of every nook and
cranny of the country and the world
they can look at antarctica if they want
to
they can pull out their smartphones i
wonder what's going on in the south pole
right now and just and look at it
which is something that i often do i
check on the south pole just because
like why not
it's it's a it's a if you're gonna have
this stupid phone carrying the fact that
you could just pull out your phone and
look at satellite imagery imagery of the
entire planet is that's a that's awesome
why not make use of that
well they've never done that no because
they know they have no curiosity about
the world instead they're just looking
at tick tock videos
you know they can actually see
the entire country and yet they know
less about it than the average american
in the year 1802 back before the lewis
and clark expedition had even reached
the pacific ocean the pacific ocean by
the way ladies is the one on the west
side it's the one that you're right next
to in los angeles
people knew more about what the world
looked like at a time when every map was
speculative and wrong
that's the reality
and we know that people are this stupid
not just because of youtube videos but
because every survey poll or study done
on the subject has verified it americans
are
it's a fact woefully ignorant about
history geography civics everything
proven by all the available data
and the problem only gets worse with
each successive generation even as each
successive generation is more educated
than the last consider this gen z
is the most educated generation in the
history of the world
and yet they don't know anything
so to emphasize again those women in the
video are current ucla students
accepted into the school will surely
graduate with honors probably and yet
they don't even know that the united
states has a capital much less can they
name it
so what are the takeaways here
too many to list but i'll give two
to start with i'm going to climb back up
on my familiar soapbox and once again
declare that the greatest threat to our
democracy is the fact that so many
people are allowed to participate in it
we have too many people voting
the people in that video know absolutely
nothing about the country they live in
or its political system and yet they're
allowed to participate in that system
and their voice counts just as much as
yours or mine
we might as well give voting rights to
animals at the zoo or vegetables at the
produce section at the grocery store if
we're going to give them to the sorts of
idiots who can't tell you which ocean
resides directly to our east
the idea that voting is a right which
comes with no responsibilities at all is
total
madness every right carries
responsibilities everyone needs to
understand this and the responsibility
of voting the most essential
responsibility of all is to maintain a
basic level of awareness and engagement
if you can't do that
or you don't want to do it
then there's no reason why you should be
permitted to vote
why should we and you can't vote
actually even when you do vote you're
not really voting you're just tossing
darts at the broad side of a barn with
your eyes closed
if you're gonna let abject morons vote
you might as well just let you know let
blind people obtain driver's licenses
while we're at it it's exactly the same
sort of thing
second takeaway
i am tempted to say that the education
system is a failure
because of stuff like this but
that wouldn't be exactly right now it's
true that the system um
it's a system which which the youngest
generation is filtered through over the
course of a decade and a half or even
longer and yet they come out on the
other end of it knowing absolutely
nothing at all
so at first glance the education system
seems like an enormously expensive piece
of factory assembly line equipment meant
to make chairs or something and yet all
it does is spit out hunks of wood and
plastic on the other end it takes the
raw material
and
produces a mangled pile of the same raw
material
in the case of the factory equipment you
would just junk the whole thing
and uh and eat the cost and rework your
entire chair making process
it seems that we should do the same
thing with the education system and we
should
the education system is a catastrophe
and should be ripped down to the studs
and rebuilt from scratch but it's not a
failure technically
the reason it's not a failure is that
our modern education system is not
trying to create
knowledgeable intelligent
uh mature responsible americans that's
not what it's trying to do
if it were trying to do that then we
could rightly say that it has failed in
spectacular fashion but that's not the
education system's goal it is instead by
design and intention
simply an ideological indoctrination
mechanism meant to create disciples of
the leftist religion who will also be
docile compliant easily manipulated
serfs
useful to the to the ruling regime
those people in the video
stupid pathetic oblivious are exactly
the sorts of people the system is trying
to create it is not a failure
it is a resounding success
the machine is functioning smoothly
and with great efficiency
and that is all the more reason
why it needs to be demolished
and that is why ultimately in light of
that video
everybody in it but also the education
system itself
is today cancelled
and that'll do it for the
this section of the show is we move over
to the members block of the show and uh
if you're not a member yet go to
dailywire.com become a member and we'll
see you over there
if not godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you